hello my awesome jacket rights I want to
play a game it's been severed your since
the last song movie which is are 10
years since the last time anyone gave a
[ __ ] will you stick around in this
review to hear me tell you if you should
care live or die make your choice
[Music]
jigsaw so jigsaw is the newest movie in
the saw franchise look at that after saw
3d the final chapter it's never final
it's been seven years since the last Saw
movie in saw Canon it's been 10 since
jigsaw died but apparently he's added
again with new victims new games new
traps that don't feel quite so new
really haven't at this point you've seen
it all there's nothing the Saw franchise
can throw at you that you haven't seen
yet that's what's so great about saw one
it was new it was twisted it was [ __ ]
up started a whole genre of torture porn
every Saw movie since has had an element
of that mystery this movie isn't without
mystery but really you look at the traps
and there's no way anyone could set them
up it all hinges on whoever's doing this
being psychic there's a scene where
someone's leg is in peril they're in
that trap it's like the knew that he was
gonna do that didn't these two other
people do this other thing and they're
in this trapped room but what if that
dude didn't trap his leg in the trap and
the whole thing we just fall apart it's
like [ __ ] [ __ ] common stupid chicks
generally speaking the acting in this
movie is pretty mediocre also par for
the course for some saw movies so really
the first trap they breezed right
through then there's a second trap that
they get through pretty quickly there's
only a select few traps and there's this
whole investigation of people is a
jigsaw is it not is he back this isn't
the worst installment of the Saw
franchise not at all said the best was
not the worst for me is the first three
saw sword saw and then jigsaw dies I'm
like I who gives a [ __ ] and Hoffman guy
is doing is or whatever this movie does
what it needed to do what it intends to
do we just dip its toe in the water see
if anyone gives a [ __ ] if this movie
makes money I imagine there'll be
another Saw movie after this if it
doesn't and no big loss they try bunny
thing is in a world worth saw is known
for its torture porn element the
tortures not really as graphic as it's
been in other Saw movies it's not
necessarily a good or bad thing it's
just a thing I've seen far worse than
other saw films best I can say it is if
you're a fan of the Saw franchise you
might enjoy this one if you've never
liked the Saw movies before this is not
gonna change your mind not like you're
gonna watch this be like oh [ __ ] what
have I been missing I never got it
before but now that's not gonna be like
that by the time this movie wrapped up
and I walked out I was like there's
enjoyment to be had in here and that's
coming from someone who really enjoyed
the Saw movies back in the day and I
will say jigsaw is probably most
entertaining if you're a bit drunk yeah
and now it's a pool so here we are you
now know what did you see
from the beginning of this video all the
way to here to see what I rated it
without watching the review the rating
is not what matters the review is but
now you've made your choice and on that
bright no jigsaw have you guys seen it
what did you think about her what your
favorite saw movie of them all whatever
it is whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]